[تصفيق]
لقطات عسكرية أوكرانية لضربة بطائرة بدون طيار
وقاذفة صواريخ روسية،
الحرب الدموية بين روسيا
وأوكرانيا تدور على الأرض
وفي السماء باستخدام طائرات بدون طيار
ومركبات جوية بدون طيار أو طائرات بدون طيار، بعضها
لم يكن مخصصًا للاستخدام العسكري أبدًا.
هي إحدى الأسلحة في هذه الحرب، وهي
طائرة بدون طيار يمكن أن تطير بعيدًا خلف
الخطوط الأمامية وتحمل قنبلة قوية
مجهزة لإلقاء شظايا مميتة
مثل هذه. أعطى الدفاع الإقليمي لأوكرانيا لشبكة
CNN نظرة حصرية على ما
تبقى من طائرة بدون طيار مسلحة تم
تصنيعها أصلاً في الصين.
يقول جهاز أمن الدولة الأوكراني إن أحد العملاء أبلغ عن
إطلاق الطائرة بدون طيار من
الأراضي التي تحتلها روسيا وأن القوات
أسقطتها في الساعة الثانية صباحًا يوم السبت، وهذا أمر
رائع، حيث يوضح الضابط
أن رجاله أسقطوا هذه الطائرة بدون طيار باستخدام
بنادق، نعم، لذلك كانت الطائرة بدون طيار
كانت الطائرة بدون طيار تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض ومرئية
للعين المجردة، وأخبرني أن
هذا هو المكان الذي سقطت فيه القنبلة على العبوة
الناسفة على الطائرة بدون طيار، حيث قامت
قوات الطائرة بدون طيار بتزويد القنبلة غير المنفجرة التي يبلغ وزنها 20 كيلوغرامًا
بالمتفجرات، ثم انطلقوا سريعًا بحثًا عن
غطاء،
وتعرف الضباط على الطائرة بدون طيار على أنها من طراز Mugen
5  والتي أكدت الشركة المصنعة Mugen Limited
أيضًا لـ CNN أن
مقر الشركة في شامان الصين، حيث تصمم هياكل الطائرات بدون طيار
لأنشطة مثل
الوقاية من حرائق الغابات والزراعة. وقد
أصبحت طائرات Mugen بدون طيار متاحة
للبيع في الأسواق الصينية عبر الإنترنت مثل
Alibaba وTaobao مقابل ما يصل إلى حوالي
خمسة عشر ألف دولار، مما دفع  أطلق بعض
المدونين التقنيين عليها لقب
طائرة علي بابا بدون طيار Mugen 5، وتدين أي
استخدام لطائراتها بدون طيار في ساحة المعركة،
مضيفين أن الشركة توقفت عن قبول
الطلبات من كل من روسيا وأوكرانيا
منذ بداية الحرب ولكن في
يناير عرضت القوات الروسية هذه
الصور لـ  ما هو أيضًا Mugen Five الذي
يدعي الجيش الروسي أنها
طائرة بدون طيار أوكرانية أسقطها
خبير الطائرات بدون طيار كريس لينكولن جونز يسمي هذه
الطائرات بدون طيار العسكرية بالقنابل الغبية. هذه الطائرة بدون طيار التي كنا ننظر
إليها ستكون أكثر فعالية إذا كان
لديها لائق  يقول
ضابط الجيش البريطاني السابق المتخصص في
حرب الطائرات بدون طيار إنه يتوقع المزيد من قوة
عسكرية عظمى مثل روسيا،
ويبدو أن هذه طريقة بدائية للغاية وغير متطورة
وليست متقدمة جدًا من الناحية التكنولوجية
لإجراء العملية
الأجنبية